[Música]
[Aplausos]
en otro día me contaron que en un
supermercado de esta ciudad contrataron
a un chico sordo para la reposición de
productos en las góndolas y demás hasta
ahí todo bien pero me enteré también que
a los días un señor se fue a quejar con
el gerente de esta sucursal diciéndole
que le había hecho una consulta a este
empleado y éste había tardado en
responderle que no se habían entendido y
que él se había sentido muy incómodo
porque había tardado mucho en darse
cuenta que era sordo
y dice que está bueno la iniciativa de
que no sean contra todos pero que tenían
que haber puesto un cartel
un cartel o sea un cartel yo me imagino
las ganas que tuvo ese gerente lo que se
aguantó ese tiempo para decirlo
un cartel deberíamos haberle puesto un
cartel si a usted que diga estúpido no
carteles etiquetas saben que se ve a ti
que estás los productos llevan etiquetas
las personas nos llevan etiquetas
o a ver pongamos a pensar como le
decimos a una persona que no puede ver
como como lo denominamos
no por el nombre tiene nombre de una
persona a las personas tienen nombre
esta anécdota es un claro ejemplo de un
prejuicio negativo que hay sobre las
personas con discapacidad y así entre
millones
porque hay con una connotación super
peyorativa sobre lo que es la
discapacidad no se imagina estas
personas como tristes miserables con un
tono sepia así con un tango de fondo
y es mucho mucho más distinto a eso es
mucho distinto a eso es otra cosa pero
bueno así les somos mucho más útiles a
la sociedad no así que somos útiles los
discapacitados no
porque le mostramos al resto que son
normales es la capacidad de mostrar al
resto que son normales que llegan a su
casa y digan por suerte no soy así
me llamo cairo y estoy discapacitado
pero todos lo estamos todos somos
incapaces para hacer ciertas cosas no
hay 22 actitudes que han estado ligadas
a las personas que tenemos alguna
diferencia no siempre generamos dos
cosas
lástima
dios siempre 22 sensaciones no lastima
y cómo es y ternura cuando claramente
preferimos tener otras dos admiración y
asombro y creo que casi todo el tiempo
lo que vamos a estar tratando es de
romper con esto no de alejarnos de la
lástima
yo por lo menos algo todos los días con
esa actitud con la de alejarme y la
lástima porque creo que la lástima es el
peor sentimiento que se puede sentir por
un ser humano por el lástima no conduce
a nada lastima no genera nada bueno las
claves el presentimiento que se puede
sentir por un ser humano porque no
construye nada solamente te hace sentir
mejor a vos en base a tu mirada que
tienes sobre otro es el pleno
sentimiento y creo que de maradona
podemos decir un montón de cosas y
podemos destacar un montón de cosas
negativas pero hay una frase que nadie
puede discutir que dijo el diego y es
lástima a nadie y posta creo eso qué
lástima a nadie por eso si algún día le
ofrecen ayuda a una persona con
discapacidad y ésta no se las acepta no
se sientan mal les está haciendo eso
para demostrarles que puede se quiere
dejarle a la lástima y en mi caso el
humor fue el mecanismo de empoderamiento
para salir a dar admiración y alejarme
de la lástima
en el camino de paso generar alguna que
otra risa en el mejor de los casos no
así era yo yo tengo 28 años y cuando era
chiquito era así este es el momento de
la charla
pero hace 20 años pasó algo que me
cambió la vida se prendió fuego la casa
donde yo vivía en la parte de abajo de
la escalera y yo quedé atrapado en el
piso de arriba por cuestiones de
inseguridad no pude salir por las
ventanas porque tenía rejas fijas así
que me fui a la habitación más alejada
del foco ígneo hasta cerró todas las
puertas hasta que empezó a entrar el
humo a entrar a entrar y me desmayé
me desperté tres meses después en el
hospital garraham de capital federal
luego un coma inducido producto de la
gravedad de las quemaduras que yo tenía
y bueno ahí arrancaba otra vida no está
ya tenía un moro igual con los stickers
claramente no era tu día
en el hospital aprendí a escribir
aprendí a dibujar aprendí a pintar y
aprendí a cambiar los colores los
canales de la tele con los dedos de los
pies y yo estaba muy orgulloso de mi
logro y un día vino un médico y le
muestro lo que yo podía hacer y muy loco
de mí sino de ver más vamos a usar las
manos para hacer eso los pies solamente
para caminar
y fue un consejo que me acompañó hasta
el día de hoy porque nunca utilice una
prótesis porque yo creo que resignarse y
aceptarse son dos cosas distintas y yo
decidí aceptarme quizás algo fácil para
la plasticidad cerebral de un niño de
ocho años pero bueno me acompaña hasta
hoy porque hasta el día de hoy utiliza
las manos para todo para escribir
para cocinar para bañarme para usar la
computadora inclusive para eso que los
más asquerosos están pensando
la escuela primaria no tuve mayores
problemas solo alguna que otra mirada
extraña donde sea que iba y comentarios
del estilo de mama es el ine tiene patas
de perro en las manos
mira mamá es el que está todo derretido
cosas así pero bueno son niños entienden
la cuestión se complejizó un poco en la
secundaria donde la crueldad es moneda
corriente y las hormonas hace en
ebullición de una manera extraña y
recibía comentario de todo tipo desde
manco a quemado dijo de todo lo que se
imagina en el medio y me daba mucha
bronca me ha dado mucha bronca mucha ira
y hasta el punto de que llegue a irme a
las manos con un compañero
imagínense que les pide un banco o sea
más que más que el golpeteo de la
dignidad no
pero bueno fue mi manera de canalizar lo
en el momento y hacer muchos chistes
conmigo chistes que me molestaban
chistes que no me gustaban pero un día
intenté un enfoque diferente intenta
empezar a reírme de manera falsa al
principio no de manera falsa empezará a
reírme de los chistes que ellos hacían y
como muchas relaciones humanas es que
arranca fingiendo termina sintiendo me
empezaron a dar risa en serio los
chistes y ahí es cuando decidí subir
otro escalón no cuando hice propia la
diferencia ahí decidí subir otro escalón
no
cuando no se dieron cuenta de que no
sólo no me afectaban los chistes que
ellos hacían sino que me divertían
propuse otra cosa decidí subir otro
escalón y como muchos futbolistas dicen
la mejor defensa es un buen ataque pero
puse un ataque y empecé a hacer chistes
yo mismo de mí y me di cuenta que no
solo me divertía sino que divertía y a
su vez los chistes que ellos hacían
tenían que ser mejores que los que los
chiste que ellos hacían tienen que ser
mejores que los que yo hacía entonces
les subía la vara no
al principio de chistes tontos como que
jairo darme una mano bueno esto es lo
que me queda he hecho que los cinco
buenos choco cuatro itv1 hasta chistes
más complejos como éste
creo que un poco esta frase define mi
proceso como revolucionario
el comediante asume la brutalidad del
mundo y le responde con mayor brutalidad
porque fue eso a asumir lo que me había
ocurrido y tratar de responder con una
apuesta superadora
y realmente yo creo que todos tenemos un
lenguaje salvador
y en mi caso fue el humor el humor me
salvó el humor no solo me salvó el humor
me salvó la vida fue ese lenguaje
salvador esa energía superadora que hizo
que yo transforme todo lo que me había
pasado en algo positivo y yo creo que
todos tenemos un lenguaje salvador todos
tenemos esa energía adentro algunos la
depositan en el humor otros en la música
otros en la pintura otros en el baile
otros en el deporte lo importante es que
encuentre el suyo y lo trabajen en el
día a día
si me fui muy audaz
desde chiquito me encantaban los
desafíos y el desafío más grande en mi
vida fue volver a vivir mi vida
así
pero por suerte si los estilos son
graciosos pero por suerte mis carencias
formaron habilidades que configuraron un
poco lo que soy hoy soy un tenista en
comunicación social comediante y docente
de stand up si me gano la vida contando
chistes de manos
reír es fácil es fácil pero hace rey es
muy difícil y reírse de uno mismo más no
pero por suerte para escalar no se
necesitan manos
de hecho yo escale por no tenerlas
y a base de chiste me convertí en el
primer comediante de stand up de paraná
formando la primera productora de
eventos de este tipo en mayo 2014 y
desde ese momento a hoy no he parado de
actuar recorriendo casi todas las
provincias del país inclusive países
limítrofes como chile y uruguay y a su
vez saliendo para toda latinoamérica por
un importante canal este año
así que podríamos decir que el humor no
solo me salvó la vida sino que hoy
también es mi medio de vida
hay una gran preocupación de muchos
sectores por encontrar la correcta
manera de denominar nos a nosotros los
discapacitados pero gracias que ese
tranquilo tenemos nombres nada más
muchos definen por carencia ciego sordo
rengo manco mudo otros por adicción
personas con capacidades diferentes o
personas con capacidades especiales pues
fueran especie de superhéroe no igual
tranca ya vamos a llegar a esa parte
la cuestión es discapacitado con
respecto a qué o quién por qué si
medimos la capacidad que tiene un pez
para trepar un árbol o la de un gato
para bucear probablemente lleguemos a la
conclusión de que están discapacitados
cuando en realidad lo que está errado es
la prueba para determinar sus
capacidades
parece rando les quiero decir que si
estoy discapacitado pero ustedes también
porque bajo el timo logía de la palabra
discapacidad que quiere decir carencia
de una capacidad bajo esta definición
estamos englobados todos todos somos
carentes de capacidades y por suerte
somos carentes porque una carencia es
una habilidad en potencia entonces lo
que tenemos que hacer es buscar esa
falencia que tenemos y transformarla en
una virtud en una virtud personal que
solamente nosotros podamos tener
yo por ejemplo no poder contar con los
dedos de la mano pero sí puedo contar
chistes sobre los dedos de mis manos
reírse de uno mismo es un superpoder y
como todo superpoder conlleva una gran
responsabilidad
muchas gracias